we got a little update here on our bud
hey and now i gotta make it very clear
i've really turned around on owen
okay i'm a fan of owens now because how
are you here you're bear
gee just took everyone's money and
bought a giant piece of land how great
is it not only did he buy that land
but now he's telling people that he said
to go
he's not letting him on the property and
here's why and a lot of people are
standing at the gates
of bertaria knowing they can't get in
they don't have what it takes
they gave him money they gave him a 400
dollars
four hundred dollars bro how tight is
that dude
[ __ ] take a bunch of money from
people
yeah you're gonna be part of this thing
and then go well no this that's cult
[ __ ]
that's legit cult [ __ ] that's like take
the money and then go but but god
decided you were not worthy
to enter the kingdom you're joking but
wait till he hears that what do you hear
this
sitting at the gates of beretaria
knowing they can't get in
they don't have what it takes and they
thought they did and that's probably why
they hate me for it because they're like
you gave me hope
and i'm like i don't even know you man
i've never met you
oh
we covered when he was talking about
bertaria
we covered when he gave money you got to
hang out at bertario we we're on this
okay
he had a vetting class online
i know i you know man i
again
you know look dude look this is
obviously evil as [ __ ] right
but it's so brazen that i i kind of
it it's sort of like all right like you
remember the sky king right he stole a
plane just did batteries
first of the ocean i'll never forget
this guy king
recipes captain bibo wrestling thank you
we posthumously made him a captain by
the way
um but like it's one of those things
where it's like on the surface of what
he did
what he did was wrong right i mean he
stole an airplane he put people in
danger
a lot of things you could if you look at
something on the surface you go
okay what he did was technically wrong
right but it was the brazenness
of it right this is i got to appreciate
this on some level
it's so brazen he's he's
owen has transcended to a level where
he's just in like this this is a level
of insanity
that borders on brilliant i love it he
took all their money and then he's like
yeah it's not my fault you're not
spiritually worthy to enter my
my gates you that's you that's on you
his kingdom
i love
oh this is the best even know you man
i've never met you
i don't know you just gave me money you
should have hope if you're capable of it
if you can rise if you can
get out of your fear hate like porn
like pill [ __ ] okay but let's say
you're not on porn let's say you don't
do porn you don't do pills you don't do
any of that stuff
what is the vetting process is there a
vetting process
yeah do i have to not do pills and jerk
off for like
uh remember that that sign up sheet
thing that we we saw
a couple weeks ago uh oh yeah yeah we
covered yeah we covered it on the
patreon show
oh yeah that that was the vetting
process okay
so a a wordpress form
yes all right but because they can in
their mind
it's my fault for giving them hope you
told me i could be better you told me i
could have a homestead you sure could
have a family
did you take pills this morning
but how do you know what prescription
drugs people like i'm
because some people are on pills they
need they need to like heart medication
or pills they need to like not kill
somebody yeah
yeah are you mad at everyone do you
blame no no
they're matt oh and i'm gonna explain to
you why people are mad
they're mad because you took their money
and promising them they could do
something and now they can't
i reposted it in the show links the
vetting process
that's that's like that's like if you if
you were to pay like 500 dollars for
a jetblue right 500
for a jet blue flight and then before
you board they go uh did you take pills
this morning
sorry you can't be on the plane
he
he's setting himself up for a hell of a
lawsuit oh absolutely
like this was this started off kind of
funny
you know what i mean but this has turned
into a thing that like
i mean i don't know if people would even
necessarily here's the thing
would people have a solid case maybe not
but it's owen benjamin and people
despise him and he might lose just out
of spite
but he this is jesus dude
name other people for all your problems
you blamed you've been to g
like there is like real hell
here now there's a real darkness in the
world that a lot of the bears are not
feeling or engaging in and because of
that the demons at the gate
want us that they're so mad they're like
how why would you give me hope i'm like
you still have hope it's it's less than
six months ago
but you still can get out of it you
still every day is a new chance
it's like you made me believe in
victoria i'm like dude
you know that i'm just a guy man you
know the obstacles i faced
crowdfunding land to build on
how quickly do you think i can pull this
up in a year i had secured land
and started the building process
shooting a documentary with many bears
documentary
almost the thing that he hates and
that's that's that's owen's thing
he always becomes that video uh for
those of you that donated to
bertaria and first rio and all that an
added bonus
is you're going to get a hateful says
documentary
he's an idiot and it makes me think of
like you had a guy working in your
clerical office
and his name was terry yeah and you're
like yeah we call them documentary
uh for those of you that donated to
bertaria and for urcerio and all that
an added bonus is you're gonna get a
full documentary out of it
oh cool and it's looking incredible i
just want to show you guys the
video quality of it and kind of like hey
guys
send us send me like 500 000 i'm gonna
buy a bunch of land with a house on it
and then i'm gonna make a documentary
about my cool new house for you guys
isn't that kind of what he's doing
though yeah i'm gonna just give me half
a mil
i'm gonna buy a dope house and then i'm
gonna do a documentary about how cool my
how awesome i'm going to do a
documentary
thing about how dope my pool is
and i'm going to send that to all you
idiots that gave me money
good presents i'm looking at i'm looking
at the form right now one of the lines
is
your submission of this form is not a is
not fulfillment or promise of
fulfillment of any products or services
doesn't matter he [ __ ] he's still
promised a lot yeah he says that now but
the video that he initially put out
the gofundme and all that did not say
that he might be saying that now
you don't think there's a dozen people
like davey croco and milker nation and
johnny arcade that don't have
probably 50 clips of him saying like
this will be this and then if you
if you donate this we'll let you camp
out and he said all that [ __ ] so
you could say whatever you want about
what's in writing but if you're
you can like people think that just
because you get a contract right
or or because you put something in
writing that you're protected from any
kind of like
you know legal ramifications but it's
like i could put a bunch of disclaimers
on my show
and then also break all of those
disclaimers by like wink wink
promising people things and i could
still get brought to court and
and destroyed by the way hal 9000 says
the documentary
the documentary is entitled rubbing your
nose in it
yeah and look we the thing is this isn't
something we're listening to second hand
we watched the videos on this show a
year ago when he was talking about this
and he was saying yeah you know make
some money and then all the bears he
said things like
all the bears could come and we could
hang out man you know if you donate 400
you know you come you can hang out and
go camping i'm sure i'm sure you said
you couldn't live there
buddy but it was supposed to be this
thing where you go camping you guys
could all hang out and you would have
this
this commune of bears and i think what
he's finding out is is that that was a
bad idea
bob talking about foundations
all right where is it here it is this is
the documentary standing here it's all
about the foundation
truth on a foundation you couldn't get a
boom mic um that's coherent i think it's
playing
alphabet speaker amazon they'll tell you
what's
what the foundation is not the
rainforest no no the foundation ends up
being
consume and and appeal to your vices
you know yeah and by good we mean cut
your willy one's also
really fat for a guy who's being like
healthy yeah like if you're out there
i mean i'm not saying based on like oh
you should be a gym bro but like
suppose he quit drinking i suppose he
quit putting all these pharmaceuticals
and [ __ ] in his body suppose he quit all
that
he's out there he's supposedly farming
and tending the land and building and
lifting up
logs like you would naturally become
skinnier
you wouldn't just be this fat guy in a
hoodie that it just seems like he's
doing a whole lot of sitting around
there's the donated invited to come be
part of it
okay let's hear that i want to hear that
i back up a little bit because i missed
that line
here i had secured land and started the
building process
shooting a documentary with many bears
that donated
invited to come be part of it you can
now see why i was a little
uh selective given the amount of media
attention i was getting imagine if i had
a crazy guy there
but you don't don't even bother i know
what you're gonna say
i think we don't need to say it i think
everybody knows what the line is
okay fine say the line bart
you're the guy bro imagine if they had a
crazy guy there
yeah imagine that huh
his poor kids man
that that's i'm not taking that risk i'm
not putting my family at risk
you know yeah i'm only i'm yeah i'm not
gonna put my family at risk i'm only
gonna have
a couple of dozen people from my fan
base living on my property
i'm not gonna put my family in danger
oh and if you have one fan living on
your property you're putting your family
in danger
am i right am i wrong here you do you
know these people
are yeah you're like the ones i vetted
they're good
you still got to go to sleep at night
right like i don't know
seems weird and so it's like your anger
is directed should only be directed at
yourself
and it's not my responsibility to save
you or help you
or it's like every day you do that
can i help somebody in the chat out ray
jenkins says does he hallucinate what is
he always looking at he's looking
up and to the right he's lying see what
he's doing is
uh ray maybe this will help he's lying
that's why he's constantly looking off
because he doesn't want to
when you're looking at a camera or
you're looking at a screen right
there's still a certain element of like
if i look at the camera right
that's still kind of looking in somebody
in the eye right right so when you lie
you don't like looking people in the
eyes but a lot of people that do
streaming and stuff
also won't even look at the camera
directly when they speak because
they're lying he's lying that's why he's
constantly trying to come up with
weird analogies because he's lying
it's not my responsibility to save you
or help you
or it's like every day you do that to
yourself
and so then this anger comes at me and
they need they need a
um a symbol of it i was a knight he's a
scammer
oh no he did buy the land oh he's got a
military
you just said he was a scammer and that
all the money he was keeping for himself
so now that's not true no no he's used
the money to actually have a
like a castle in the military now five
minutes ago you said
he kept the money and so you so you lied
about this
kept the money to build like see what
he's doing this is what people do when
they're lying
they they try to mix all of the
arguments together
and just poison the well owen
you keeping the money and you building
yourself
a huge compound are not mutually
exclusive things
that's that's not that's not what we're
saying they're not saying you didn't
even build anything what they're saying
is you're a scammer because you promised
all these things
to share them and now you're not sharing
them
but you're like well which one is it huh
did i did i keep your money
or did i use your money to build a
badass [ __ ] private property
well i mean i think we could say that
that would be one and the same right
jesus christ that would be like that
would be like me saying guys i'm raising
money
to help out one of the fans who's sick
and i raised like
70 grand and i go out and buy a brand
new bmw suv
and then i'm fighting with fans for
weeks going well which one is it i mean
because
all these liars out there people are
saying oh merch kept the money and then
half the people are saying oh merch
bought a brand new bmw suv with it
well which one is it and it's like well
it's both you
you kept the money and then spent it on
the thing that you
said specifically was not the thing you
were going to spend it on that's still
keeping the money
he's doing mega church pastor apostle
david taylor level [ __ ] right now yeah
the money to actually have like a castle
in a military
now five minutes ago you said he kept
the money
and so you said you lied about both
things
i'm scared i'm scared i'm scared that's
all i hear is i'm scared i'm scared
anger anger because when you're in the
fear of vibration it's easy to flip that
switch to anger
fear vibrations what the [ __ ] dude
it's just a fear of vibrations
it's just a sweet sensation no
come on come on where's his george feel
it feel it i wouldn't let him wear
george to the camp i thought it would uh
because we had a no female policy at the
uh not gay at all
it's pretty good at the uh
you literally had to know girls
come on man this is funny so you you
built a
you built a compound in the woods to
hang out with your men friends
and you and you made a and you made a no
girls allowed rule
what are you [ __ ] what are you eight
years old man
what are you one of the [ __ ] little
rascals what is he doing
i have a video it of him yeah i do
this is this is the cop this is the
compound
what do you what oh and look i hate
women too but you gotta have a couple
around right like
oh my god i don't know dude baitari
looks pretty lit
no he with no grace i'm not kidding
that is so child like we're starting a
compound boys no girl
like okay so uh irrational times made
the song
the boy's boys voice yeah and it's like
i listen to that like because it's part
of my preview music for night wave and
it's the gayest song
it's the stupidest song but it's funny
because he's purposely saying the things
like
no girls allowed just as boys like it's
it's it's supposed to be funny but owen
un ironically made a boys boys boys club
which is looks pretty fun to me though
that's so [ __ ] funny man no girls
allowed
is so like look man i know i'm hard on
women sometimes but like
god damn could you imagine they go look
we're gonna live on an island with no
women you'd be like
absolutely not no am i am i fighting in
some kind of
war for for some kind of purpose no
we're just gonna go live in the woods
with no women
that sounds horrible i'm out i'm tapping
out he made him he
dude he he hustled his fans out of
hundreds of thousands of dollars to
build a compound in the woods
with his fellow friends with his boys